Mark: "OKAY IM READY!"
Dlive: "Yeah"
Mark: "READY!"
Entoan: "LETS DO IIIIIIIT!"
Mark: "Okay.."
Wade: "DEAD BY DAYLIGHT, TAKE......"
Entoan: "300..."
Wade: "Seven...teen..?"
Mark: "Dead by daylight take like... five for me.."
"Geez"
"I haven't been able to get a single episode"
"HI EVERYBODY!!! Whatever, ok..."
*laughing*
Entoan: "Perfect intro!"
Mark: "That's me."
(Wade's Unintelligible Gibberish) HII
Mark: (Yells) "HI!!!"
"Okay here we go."
Dlive: "Oh!"
Mark: "'It's what I do when I see a pretty girl across the street"
(Yells) "HI!!!!"
(Still Yelling) "IM MARK!!!!"
*girl impression* Dlive: "Date meeee!"
*giggle*
Mark: "That's a bit aggressive.."
"Don't you think?"
"What if I just wanna talk to her?"
(More Unintelligible Speaking)
I have re-
Dlive: "Hey yo ma, how you doing?"
Entoan: "I have regrets... I didn't say anything!"
*words* Dlive: "... totally would say yes"
Wade: "We know JP's dating strategy now"
Dlive: *mmm* Mark: *uhhhhhh*
Entoan: "Don't judge my dating" Dlive: "Oooh,"
Entoan: "strats.." Dlive: "the Cornfield..."
Mark: "Wade..."
Entoan: "Wade, are you that dude?"
which
yeah. which are you?
"we're gonna have a good time here."
Well he's not the wraith
He's the other thing
Ding-dong
Uh-huh.
Well maybe he's just saving his dings!
can't be unleashing all the dongs.
"wooo."
"He's got a ding-a-ling?"
ooop yep, Ding-Dong!
"OH CRAP"
"i'm outta there"
"Alright JP you got this"
"No I don't."
"I'm gonna die."
"He's gonna find me."
"And it's gonna be over..''
"Where you going to run to?"
"Nowhere."
"You selling this house, you selling this house"
Wade!
Wade don't..
Wade, no..
Come on!
Come on, Wade!..
No! Come on!
What are you doing?
Wade!
Why are you being like that, Wade?
"Be a distraction"
"Hey, Waaaade!"
"Hey, Waaadeboo!"
"Oh you're scared to turn the other way"
"Hey turn around!"
Wade don't--
Wade, don't do things.
Wade don't do things.
Wade don't -don't -don't be things
Don't do things
Wade don't do any- AHHH
Wade don't do things!
Oh is this revenge?
Is this revenge for being...?
Revenge for what?
For what everything but I wasn't doing
that
Revenge- AHH
What the hell?
I wasn't doing that!
I didn't mean to go through the window!
I didn't mean to go to the window I
meant to pull down the wood!
And you ran right back at me!
Why did that happen?
I didn't go through the window!
To the walls
You just gonna
You're just going to watch me, aren't you
Gonna watch me
You're going to watch me aren't you.
I'm going to be the bigger man!
(Uncontrollable giggling)
I don't think- I don't think that
I don't think that's anything that you are
think there's anything that you are (That's so nice)
I don't think- I don't think anything that you are is the bigger man, Wade
Okay, so guys new strategy,
now that were just all together standing in one spot.
*Laughing*
What are you- what are you talking about?
Uhh go team go
OH CRAP
Ummm, I saw something I don't...
No wait! Please
JP, run for us, please
yeah, do something really distracting.
Ah, wait you jerk
I thought you were right there. I'm sorry.
Hold up we'll heal you
That's how terrible I am.
Just don't break my arm
Wade you're not terrible. You're the best, please just give me time
it looks so weird with you guys is
rubbing all over my back
Just like there there little girl.
Yeah, that's how you heal them.
uh, ok
*unimportant conversation*
They rubbed me real good
they rubbed me raw
*hahahahahaha*
okay!
well that doesn't sound good!
yup I'm up this game
This game is so a-DERKTIV, I'm aDERKDEDOIT....?
yeah all right the house has the weather
everybody
it's very bare using my heli style
duh thank you for your bear place that-
I got my twin! I got my twin
What was that?
Nothing.. You got nothing. Everything's fine
a monster see wade
Wade, i believe in you you're great
killer you're gonna do great things in
life right great and i love you need to
know about maybe I can trust you and I
don't wait wait wait stop stop
so don't worry about he's going at the
rate maybe run
all right i'm running to the middle
sized somebody all right somebody come
rub me what's up but even think about
that
there's a lot of rubbing going on
why aren't I a part of this?.. Wade leave me alone
I'm sorry do you live
nope no no no no okay
I'm I just like every day but I said
there's somebody 's upstairs! Somebody's upstairs!
Sh, Shut up!
Stop trying to sell out your team mates! >:(
Be a man!
Die for your team!
wait okay that's a bit extreme don't die
for your team
Just get seriously injured for your team
now yeah that that's preferable to do it
and wade, let's talk about this okay
look at this hey , no hey - go away!
No! I'm outta here wade, get rekt
come here buddy!
please I'm doing them. I'm not doing the generators!
I'm uh-
leave me alone! D:
wade?
wade, I think you're obsessive over me please
oh you startled me bud
oh you guys are so good at the engines
and I'm like our generators and I'm like
awful
so yeah please just keep like what you
do your thing and I'm gonna hide his
Just hush, get better at it
please trying so hard you're better at
it I i think i'm about to die
I think death is going to approach me. I- wait, didn't you get rubbed though
no no I mean I'm just saying in general
that
that's what i meant when I said death! I got
stabbed in the head
wade, this is a little excessive
please
Leave me alone! - wade you're being- you're
being totally unfair
(Wade, stop being a perv)
you need to work out your aggression and
more healthy outlets
yeah why don't we talk about it let's
just talk to you for a min
I don't know, you know yoga, pilates you
know maybe some some some some role
aromatherapy
that'd be nice maybe a massage che
I've got a mary kay Kay uh-huh
*allot of whiney ehehehe noises*
aromatherapy is not blood, blood's not
aromatherapy , AH,
Oh owe owe ouch owe ow
oh oh ow, ouch kabbibles
was wondering if that was a bad idea
wade I'm sorry I- I hear all these- PLEASE LEAVE ME ALONE
hey did you get the generators and I can
remember
I-I don't know if that's a good idea
stop rubbing people we can't stop
rubbing stopping the soul that you just
make me feel good. - What you are talking
about? you don't feel good ? You don't like
my rubbing?! ( it feels great :p) AHHRHGHH!
nobody's rubbed me yet! I'm still over here limping, JP where you at
I love you - This was supposed to be  a love rub story!
that's a different story wade.. - Can I- Can I get a rub over here?
that doesn't sound good
I wonder if I'm about to die well sorry
for coming over here!
AHHHHHHHHH - I apologize
*laughter and manly scream & sounds*
please hi yogini have been rubbed we
- wait I'm gonna die
get not related at least let Robert one
Wade, lets talk about- I haven't gotten rubbed once in my life - wade, I'm never gonna get rubbed
wade, Wade, No...
wade no.. Wade no.. - Look somebody helped you!
I didn't know that was a thing I thought
I was done for
I saved you - thank you so I'm safe and now I can rub you
yeah wait on generator you're gonna get
away from me
I'm gonna skip out you never know if
somebody you know you got to take the
time to read the bottle with a nice
let's get the crap out of me i did not
know that was a thing
what I I am uh oh I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm a prediction mom I'm a predictable
get away
arco no 10 hello
shut up am I see him he's in the
cornfield no he's not
it looks stupid or maybe he is not a
hundred percent sure about anything
anymore making a pallet
reporting live through the portal is it
murder on the loose from Wade
headquarters
he's ding donging Izzy no hunting dog
try again
we didn't marry me baby
is that good hangry birds reduction
ok ok ok ok wait no wait did someone get
this end ok nevermind forget forget
everything I was wrong
who yeah we keep going out with large
because I just heard his heartbeat
it was concerned with what is this hello
dude you shouldn't stop what
you should stop what do you pick you up
and running for the hills run with the
hare
ok no oh well that's that
that's pop out what I pursued my
reference you can do it
I don't know you Oh open one of the
exits but one of the summer - it was you
know
wait we'll be right back there are no
the very first time I ever without no
matter what it takes
I got will be you left everybody at
behind
I love them would open I don't know what
it's like me the way I like it
wait was that a very personal way that
felt personal
wait you're stupid of it stupid album do
it don't do it
No
what's gonna die gonna die
nice movie under the hills never get
over here or follow me
he thinks it's out of the question
I'm place to fit I'm just like don't
mind me hold my intestines in you want a
little rally for the round get the rep
perfect road for the pretty lady rubber
just doing this right now
oh yeah second this does that no no best
best time for rub
it's time to eat and she would be sweet
fun
no I think you guys are other door it
should time
yeah wait you may have made a horrible
air
I would you know we go without you wait
for it wait booth
Hey where are you going yep diet
Yeah I don't know you better run
I scared you off for live yeah we are very scared wade you're a good monster
good monster [LAUGHING]
Hey what are you ? A LITTLE BOY !!!
Awwww OH MY GOD !!!
[LAUGHING] HELLO !!! OK
I mean boy its gonna
awwwwww What the Fuck
HOLY SHIT BALL